right let's bring you some breaking news
the Amir of oil Rich Kuwait sheh Noah Al
Ahmed alah died on Saturday the Royal
quar has said this is after three years
that he held his position in power he
was 86 years old Bernard Smith takes a
look back at his
life almed Al jabah Al saah LED Kuwait
for a relatively short time only since
September 2020 by the end of 2021 he'd
handed most of his duties to his half
brother and designated Heir Michal
al-ahmed
alabah imir aaf had been involved in the
administration and government of Kuwait
since its full independence from Britain
in
1961 he was defense minister in Exile
when Kuwaiti tanks accompanied by Allied
Forces rumbled into Kuwait City at the
end of the first Gulf War but his role
in the runup to Iraq's invasion in
August 1990 casts a cloud over his
career
[Music]
after the Gulf War The Returning Amir
face demands from senior army officers
to investigate and dismiss then shik
noaf and another
Minister the officers said shik noaf
withdrew tanks from the border reduced
the state of alert and told the Army not
to fire on Iraqis if they crossed into
Kuwait decisions taken apparently to
avoid provoking the Iraqis shik noaf
wasn't dismissed but was appointed
social affairs minister in the post-war
government a comparatively Junior
role now afal Ahmed aljabar alabah was
born in June 1937 his family has ruled
oil Rich Kuwait continuously since the
mid 18th century he leaves behind a wife
four sons and a daughter Bernard Smith
Al
jazer well let's bring in now Muhammad
chawi he's a professor of conflict
resolution and diplomacy at George Mason
University good to have you with us so
first of all how do you think um this
passing of the Amir of Kuai let's start
with that that issue what kind of
situation what kind of impact does it
have on the regional situation qu's long
been seen of course as something of a
balanced mediator within our politics
well it raises
several question marks about the
situation in Kuwait as a gulf state that
has sought stability has sought an
Regional and international role in terms
of negotiating and mediating certain
conflicts name number one was the Qatar
blockade in 2017 Kuwait at the time has
played a major role now there is a
question mark of the political vacuum
and uh mayor NF has not lived much has
not ruled over couple of years basically
so there is this question of where KU
leans forward now in terms of who is
going to take over and also the
implications on Kuwait's foreign policy
one assumes of course it'll be Mish
Ahmed Al ja who takes over he's been
exercising already some of the powers
right it seems like this is the normal
path toward this know
about he has been in in you know in
Kuwaiti politics for some time he has
been not on front runner or you know
front face basically he has followed
actually I think now the two figures now
and Mah are still
pursuing the
same foreign policy of late a mayor
Sabah Al Ahmed Sabah he has been the
main driving force of Kuwaiti politics
for for five decades so I don't see that
Mish will bring any major surprises or a
major alterations of the Kuwait's path
in terms of sticking to a moderate
Coalition within the gulf Nations as as
well as maintaining the arabness if you
like of its politics in terms of uh in
the Palestinian case and also on that
point just talk us through where Kuwait
stands on what's become quite a divisive
issue in the Gulf relations with Israel
well I remember once I was given a
lecture in Paris and I said there there
have been three different golves there
is the Persian Gulf and the Arab Gulf
has been split into two the the
moderates and those who are you know
holding
together in in way that this process of
normalization with Israel has split the
gulf Six Nations into two camps you have
three nations including Kuwait Qatar and
Oman are supporting this choice however
we have seen since 2020 with the Trump
Administration in Washington we have
seen the imares the
bahrainis have sort of drift to this
normalization so I look at Kuwait now as
one of the key players in the first camp
that is remains loyal to the Arab issues
to the regional issues and also to deal
with the Iranians and with the other the
Turks the other you know Regional
players in in a moderate way and way
with the Positive engagement Visa the
other players in the region all right
thank you so much so much for your
analysis on that let's go over now to
bad he's the assistant professor of
history at Kuwait University joins us
from Kuwait City good to have you with
us take us through how the public is
reacting there to this
news uh this is a very sad day indeed
for Kuwait she na Al Ahmed has only done
good for the country his legacy will be
remembered fondly he has many uh
nicknames if you may he's known as the
Amir of pardon he has led the largest
reconciliation in modern Kuwaiti history
with a series of amnesties and the
returns of citizenships release of
prisoners he has also opened up uh to
the opposition and uh ex and opened the
uh Parliament again to all voices and
opened up to taking away from the
government's role really in voting for
the speaker of the house was was which
was a crucial thing to reinforce
the positionality uh of the people and
and the popular opinion if you may uh he
will also be remembered for a drastic
administrative overhaul that has started
early on in his era and that's results
we've yet to be seen uh a shuffling of
leadership positions that has been
unprecedented and a smoother government
Parliament relations in the past few
months really with an unprecedented
legislative road map that we have had
for the 2023 24 era his his era has been
quite uh notable even though it was the
third shortest lived in Kuwait's history
by ruling only for three years and three
months all right uh I don't think
there's been an announcement about um
his successor but Mish Ahmed Al jaab is
in line to take over
correct that is
correct and talk us through what's
expected from from him given his
background in
history I mean as I IED as I've said
before in other interviews is an Insider
and an outsider at the same time he has
been accompanying the previous amirs in
all of their decisions and all of their
governance practices and he comes in
with a pierce look and a view towards
preserving what Kuwait has had and has
built in the previous years and to
moving it Forward succession has been
smooth in Kuwait it is Guided by a
constitution and there is a process that
follows uh and this process will unfold
as we speak in the in the coming
days and Kuwait is one of those Gulf and
Arab countries that has perhaps a a
greater degree of democratic practice
than than at least some others although
the Amir retains ultimate Authority
right how do you see the progression of
that kind of balance of power going
forward Kuwait's political system is
quite unique it Blends the presidential
and parliamentary systems Al together so
there is the the reign of the people as
well as the reign of the Amir that come
and meet together to serve the interests
of Kuwait I see this system moving
forward is has it has gone through a lot
of Trials and I've called for some
constitutional change and I think this
is something that we can look forward to
as we strengthen
this social contract that we have
between the rulers and the
ruled in terms of foreign policy do you
expect Kuwait to remain a staunch us
Ally as it has
been Kuwait will remain a proud Arab
nation that looks first to its Gulf
neighbors and that remains in line with
its main Partnerships first and foremost
being with the US indeed and what kind
of projection do you have for how
Kuwaiti foreign policy will develop viav
especially the conflict that's going on
in Gaza and the issue that's proved very
divisive in Arab and Gulf politics which
is relations with
Israel Kuwait has been on the record as
the last to normalize with Israel when
that takes place among the various
countries and upon the return of a
Palestinian State because they need to
reclaim their state for any action to be
taken from the Kuwaiti side we have been
very clear on that position and it's a
position that meets with large support
from both people and the
government all right we'll leave it
there thanks so much for your thoughts
and Analysis on
that